people who think that are entrepreneurs
that don't work 15 to 17 hours a day
aren't one of the things that's very
dangerous if you think you're gonna be
great I highly recommend that you be
very smart about how you go about this I
would say only percent of the kids that
I'm giving money to between 20 to 25 as
you can tell I'm not traditional and so
we get the nice relationships I would
say 80% of them tell me right to my face
first that they actually have no worry
whatsoever to lose my money that it's
awesome right like I'm sure you're
thinking it too like cool I'll raise a
million bucks I'll learn a fuckload if I
lose I'm still just 26 I got plenty of
time I'll take all that experience and
I'll go apply it and so a lot of people
right now they're taking money and just
starting [ __ ] cuz it's easy and and who
knows and it's like [ __ ] and roll it
that check box in the lost column
eliminates you from a lot of opportunity
of the next go-around and so I think
there's a lack of thinking about legacy
and long-term marathon thinking right
now in a sprinters mentality where there
is a lot of access to capital I'd like
to think still some level of giving a
[ __ ] about 10 or 14 or 19 years out